good morning john so next week a
particularly unhinged episode of dear
hank and john is going to go up we're
just a total mess because we
accidentally talked for 90 minutes
before the podcast started so we didn't
have enough time to record the podcast
and i think that the first question that
was asked was from avery who asked i was
wondering how or if we know that the
earth is straight up and down with the
northern hemisphere on top of the
southern hemisphere on the bottom which
led to much hilarity but to continue a
discussion that you have not heard yet
because the podcast is an hour i want to
talk about a time when we humans
got something right now every there is
no uh it's all arbitrary it's just stuff
that we sort of feel and decide for
example i live in a river valley where
three rivers come together and if you're
gonna go into the bedroom valley and
you're from missoula you can actually
tell something about a person by what
they say if they are new to town and
don't have a lot of relationship with
the land they say that they're going to
go down the bitter room whereas if
they've been around for a while or they
have a deeper connection to the land
they say they're going to go up the
bitter room this is because when you're
going from missoula to the bitterroot
valley you are going south but you are
also going upstream and uphill the
bitterroot river unlike most rivers in
america though this is just by
coincidence flows from south to north
and weirdly this feels a little weird to
us even though there's no reason why a
river should go in any particular
direction like the nile also goes from
south to north this confusion implicates
as faulty the entire idea of south as
down and of course south is very very
much not down globes and maps only show
north as on top because someone decided
that who i don't know but i want to make
the very strong case that if they had to
choose and i think they did they made
get this
the right decision things are a mess in
this world and we understandably focus a
lot on the things that we got wrong for
example like that there are 12 months in
a year this is terrible if there were 13
months instead of 12 every month would
be get this 28 days long except for one
which would be 27 days long and 28 days
divided by 7 is four so every month
would have exactly four weeks in it
every month would start on a monday and
end on a sunday every holiday would
happen on the same day every year and
then at the end of the year we'd have
one month that was one day short we'd
have one week that was one day short and
we'd all be like oh this is the cute fun
week where we all act weird because
there's only six days this is a
historical screw-up that we all have to
live with forever but
maps in the past often would have either
west or east at the top and if we had
ended up in the universe where we got
stuck with this it would have been
historically bad because we spin so the
actual like location of where west is
moves around in space i can even get my
head around how hard it would be to
conceive of how the earth is if i
imagined that west was up
like it just breaks me so we absolutely
dodged a cosmic bullet here now if it
had ended up with south on the top this
would not have broken my brain but it
would have been a sub-par choice to
having north on the top because the
southern hemisphere is 80 ocean while
the northern hemisphere is just 60
percent ocean so there's twice as much
land in the northern hemisphere also 90
percent of the people live in the
northern hemisphere now what i'm not
saying is that this has no drawbacks
there are negative consequences to
having settled on north as up on maps
for example no one knows whether or not
to say up or down the bitter room more
importantly we show some unconscious
bias toward things in the southern
hemisphere and when researchers test
people they unconsciously assign more
value to places that are further north
but also there is huge value in having
some kind of standardization here where
we all agree that one part of the map is
always up and so we don't have to be
thinking about it and getting it wrong
there were pros and cons to this choice
it had negative effects but we made the
right call and we ended up avoiding a
problem that we never have to think
about whereas i always have to think
about the fact that we could have lived
in a world where halloween was always on
a friday night every year
john i'll see you on tuesday which is
some random day of the month